Now that you have the general idea down,
let's go over an example.
Say there's a part of your app that
presents use with a preferences page and
allows them to choose between two
app themes, daytime and midnight.
If you set your preference
to the midnight theme,
you probably want the app
to remember that so
you don't have to reset it
every time upon app launch.
So this would be a good place
to use NS user default.
Your device has a default database
where it stores everything from system
wide defaults to language defaults
to app-specific defaults and more.
App-specific defaults is
what we'll be focusing on.
To access the values from this database,
we'll need to call standardUserDefaults
from an NSUserDefaults object
which will return the shared
defaults object that we need.
Notice I said shared object, that means
the NSUserDefaults class has a class
method that will return a reference
to the same UserDefaults object
regardless of where we
invoke it in our program.
This is called the singleton
design pattern.
Once we have the shared user defaults
object, we can then use keys to get
values for this default object,
just like a dictionary.
In this example,
we'll use the method value for key.
But there are other methods available as
well, such as string for key, bool for
key, float for key and others.
In this example want to keep a value
that let's us know whether the midnight
theme is off or on.
So it makes sense to use a Boolean here.
So we'll first check to see if
a Boolean value already exists for
the string midnight theme on using
the if let syntax in case, doesn't.
So let's first suppose that has no idea
what we're talking about it's never
heard of midnight theme on and this
is our first time launching the app.
So here's where we'll set it.
Setting a value and its user defaults
is very similar to checking for
value and
the syntax is set value with a value And
then the key string we'll
want to use to retrieve it.
So in our case this would be a bool.
So we'll say false because no one has
flipped the midnight theme on yet.
And for key we'll put in that
midnight theme on string.
So we know that if this else
statement is being executed.
It's because our call to value for
key up here return nil meaning no
value had been set for that keystring.
So this also shows us that the app
has never been launched before
because if it had, it have a value for
midnight theme on.
So let's just add a print that shows us
that this is the apps very first launch.
And we know that after this first
launch, we will now have a value for
NSUserDefaults for
that midnightThemeOn key.
So let's go back up here and
deal with this case,
that is the case where value for
midnightThemeOn returns a value.
So we know that since we're using value
for key it's returning any object.
So the first thing we need
to do is cast this to a bool
then we can check its value.
If it is true we'll call a method
called switch to midnight.
Which makes all the UI changes
necessary to show the midnight theme.
If it's false we don't really need to do
anything because the UI is set to load
with daytime theme, in general.
But let's just add some
print statement in here so
we can see what's happening when.
Okay, so now I just need to set up an
action for when the switch gets flipped.
Let me do that now.
So when this action gets executed.
I check my switch outlet to see
whether it's turned off or on.
And then I call the appropriate
UI configuration method and
it's here that I want to update my
new preference in my user defaults.
So I hadn't a set value here to true for
midnight them on and if the theme switch
is set to off I'll put in a set value
here to false for midnight theme on.
So this should work to save our
preference, let's try it out.
Now let's switch to midnight theme.
And let's see what happens
when we close the app.
On a device you can view all your open
apps by pressing the home button twice
in rapid succession.
And then you can close
an app from there.
We can simulate this action on your
simulator by holding Cmd+Shift and
rapidly pressing the H key twice.
So Cmd+Shift+H+H and just like on
a device I can swipe up to close it.
Now let's relaunch our app and great
we see that our preference is saved.
Let's switch back to daylight and
close it again.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Awesome, it saved our
daylight preference.
But how come it didn't print this is the
first launch ever when we first ran it?
Well because I had run this app with
the NSUserDefaults already implemented
when I showed you the demo.
So how do we simulate running this
app as if it was the first time it's
ever been launched on our device?
What we need to do is reset the content
and settings of our simulator.
We'll end up doing this a lot
throughout the course so
we've included the directions for the
step in the accompanying text as well.
It's pretty simple though.
We just click simulator and then reset
content and settings and that's it.
Now we can launch the app as if it's
the first time it's on our device.
And now we get this output that
says this is the first launch ever.
So it switched the midnight theme on,
let's close the app.
Let's relaunch and
we see our preferences saved.
So awesome but there's actually an even
better place to put all this code.
And that's in our app delegate.
So I made this method called
check you first launch
which does a similar thing to what our
code in our view did load method did.
Except for the primary focus is not
whether the theme has been set or
not but in a more general sense whether
the app has ever launched before.
So similar to the code in our view
did load method we have bool for
key has launched before to check
if the app has ever launched.
And if it hasn't we know that this is
the first launch in this L section.
We can set the ball for
has launched before to true.
And here will also set the default
value for midnight theme so that we
know it's taken care for the rest of
the app and then we can go back here and
delete some of this section and
see that the app still works.
We no longer need to check if there's a
value for weWantMidnight because we know
that there is because we set it in
the app delegate which launches first.
And you can see how this would be
preferred because then you can make sure
things are set up at launch
rather than a view load and
let's run it one more time.
But first let's reset the content
in settings and launch.
And switch to midnight,
let's close our app.
Relaunch, and we see that our
preferences saved, awesome.